appris hier le décès de pierre bellemare
à l'âge de 88 ans julien a travaillé
avec lui jean luc a travaillé avec nous
également
valérie géraldine c'est vrai que voilà
on était tous vraiment très très tristes
y est on s'appelait longuement avec
valérie c'est un grand homme de
télévision et de radio tous les jeunes
qui nous regardent sachez voilà c'est un
des plus grands voilà qu'on ait connu
dans ce sens un animateur producteur
inventeur compteur il savait tout faire
et regarder on a on a des petites images
à vous montrer parce que vous voulez
vous montrer les images aussi voilà qui
nous ont fait voilà qu'on a dans la tête
et c'est vrai qu'à un moment
pierre bellemare faisait de la radio
avec nous avec valérie bénaïm et
jean-luc on a eu un fou rire vous voulez
absolument vont montrer jean-luc aussi
vous dans votre émission en toutes
lettres
mais regardez ce fou rire qu'on avait
avec lui sur europe 1 regarde ici c'est
bal musette java vous m'avez trop manqué
bande de tarbes a big poppa debout ou
blédard et à l'autre rendement d'hanouna
ouest et bah ya toujours le moine qui
joue les poux cab erhard il ya même
veine m
la bête que j'ai bouille avait voit la
série le bouffon j'apprends que tu fais
même tapis les arabes sur la tête de
maromme taper show pas triste bouffon
qu'à filmer les moines
[Applaudissements]
il était tellement drôle vous avez un
extrait coups dont vous voulez nous
parler
oui oui on a revu assez souvent mais
c'est vrai que moi j étais parce que je
le connais depuis l'âge de 15 ans je
séchais les cours en fait pour aller
assister à ces émissions et c'était
presque comme un grand père il
représentait pour moi le père le grand
père et j'ai ça a été mon premier patron
j'ai été assistante sur europe 1 et
j'étais également dans sa société parce
que est précurseur ça a été un des
premiers animateurs à avoir une société
de production et c'est lui qui a fait
l'achat en france exactement la course
alors ça s'appelle au nom de l'amour en
fait c'était une la première émission un
peu de télé réalité de retrouvailles
après il ya eu perdu de vue mais au nom
de l'amour c'est que sur france 3
j'étais assistante sur cette émission il
ya une image je pense que vous l'avez vu
le père et le fils de charles à c'est
hyper émouvant parce que en plus ils se
ressemblent comme deux gouttes soeur et
nous en coulisses je ne sais pas
pourquoi on a eu un fou rire monumental
alors que voilà normalement les images
sont émouvants pour garder maintenant il
est là monsieur dans ce studio
il a accepté de venir ici vous
rencontrez est extraordinaire monsieur
schmitt j'ai la joie de vous présenter
monsieur certains le fils que vous avez
eue avec de lise de voici
donc on ne peut pas douter en vous
voyant tous les deux un côté de l'autre
monsieur que vous avez quelque chose de
monsieur schmitt monsieur schmitt qui ne
peut plus tard alors je voulais parler
d'un fou rire qu'on a vu avec pierre
parce que c'est vrai qu'on était à la
radio avec lui et un jour il nous avait
raconté d'histoires qui l'avait déjà
raconte pierre cohen et c'est vrai que
peter cohen et on a eu je crois que
c'est un de mes plus que j'ai eues en
radio en télé on regarde bien ça se
passe en 1985 pierre cohen new yorkais
de 48 ans dit avoir été victime de
l'accident qui lui a coûté la vue de
l'oeil droit alors qu'il effectue une
croisière dans les caraïbes en fait
peter qu elle était un escroc qui n'a
jamais été pris il faut qu'on lui dit
qu'elle est d'y aller il me semble il me
semble qu hier que cette chaîne
[Rires]
je voudrais encore me tourner vers vers
daniel moreau ou parce que c'est vrai
que hier on a perdu quelqu'un qui nous
était vraiment très très cher c'est
pierre bellemare chaussures michel toi
aussi tu as tu fermes ta démission avec
bien bas grâce à toi entre autres parce
que il est fait à la radio directement
c'est vrai que peut-être on a fait plein
avec nous mais oui et voilà jean luc je
sais que toi aussi tu étais hyper fan de
pierre oui
admiratif moi c'est des souvenirs
d'enfance et puis j'ai eu la chance de
croiser des fois il avait eu la
gentillesse de faire le pilote d'une
émission il avait fait sur france 2
auparavant
après on a travaillé ensemble dans les
pieds dans le plat épicé t c'était une
mine d'anecdotes et puis quelqu'un d'une
humilité un serveur le passerai un
parcours phénoménal et il a toujours des
curieux des autres est toujours très
très généreux il se prêtait à toutes les
blagues qu'on pouvait faire un atout
c'est une leçon pour tout le monde moi
j'ai un extrait d'huile c'était sur
comédie ou et ces gens lui qui l'a
choisi c'est oui parce que c'est assez
significatif c'est pas on va pas dire
que c'est le summum de sa carrière mais
en tout cas c'était assez un
représentatif de ce qu'il avait comme
humour et ce jour là il était dans la
fuego de huy des oliviers et les
chantiers antisocial de trust
[Musique]
tu veux que ton visage en visage
le label est possible de penser à tout
ce qui n'est pas mal
[Musique]
antisocial qui perdent un sang-froid
répond je doute de ses jeunes
[Applaudissements]
hier il faisait tout moi je propose et
les dures en europe à l'édition partout
il disait toujours oui diront oui on va
le faire oui il prenait la feuille il
révisait quand c'est quand même un cas
unique parce que ça a été un pionnier il
a tout inventé à la radio à la télé
depuis les années 50 mais en même temps
il a jamais été ringards cédant dans les
années 90 il était avec christophe
dechavanne coucou c'est nous c'était
vraiment le talk show dont on parlait
ensuite il a été avec vous faites toutes
les générations le connaissent grâce à
jude en os et ios à 110,1 ici renouveler
tout le temps il a dit oui à tout et
voilà je suis très très rare dans ce
métier quelqu'un que je voudrais finir
d'un pain dernier force et c'est julien
qui à laquelle choisi sourire et qui est
exceptionnel c'est quand on faisait le
jour toutes lettres
il faut savoir quand même qu'il avait 82
ans et on se tapait si cette émission
dans l'après midi et il était la plus
value de tous et au bout d'un moment
c'est vrai que c'était fatigant il
devait y avait des fichiers l'elysée
même plus et quand ils élisent et savait
même plus qu'ils aient mais la montée
fabuleux c'est la mauvaise foi il disait
non ça ne voulait rien dire et pourtant
c'est clair
[Rires]
tu sens le même mot il n'y a pas
longtemps que l'orthographe les a
distingués pour leurs desseins de2 s
iennes avec un peson mais que des saints
au sens figuré c'est à dire que l'on
dessine désigne par ces deux monstres
car ces deux mots sont identiques
est-ce que c'est clair c'est que lui
veut rien compris et j'ai une grosse
pensée aussi pour sa femme rose mais qui
je fais des normes bisous parce qu'elle
venait souvent le voir à la radio est
vraiment pire au thé était un des plus
grands vraiment et il va beaucoup
beaucoup de manques et voilà merci
daniel reist héritage sais que vous
allez sur les molières n'oubliez pas
votre petit sac j'ai mon sac j'ai tout
merci la tenue de lumière il va très
bien merci mr